cops couldn't you know get there
sometimes or right so you paid the
see the thing about the mob is that
certain things they were really
you really could use them right and
other things it was not good
so it was kind of like it was a
double-edged sword with those guys you
know what i'm saying
i mean if you really were in the gym and
somebody was going to hurt you and you
went to them
and they said who's going to hurt you
really what no no okay i'll talk to them
right then they saw the guy and they
said look that's my friend
now his problem is my problem which is
now your problem right
and that that's it nobody would bother
you so and growing up with them it was
great because i was able to write about
them
right well then i want to ask you when
was you remember
not the first day of the movie not the
first day
of the of the play when was the first
moment you put pen to paper and started
to begin to write a bronx tale
and did you like friends in the
neighborhood call you a certain name
because you were a writer because you
were right yeah because yeah well you
know
when i was younger yeah when i was 17 18
if i would write i was i used to write
poetry on those short stories they said
what are you what
are you what are you what are you what
is it the zagged survey
what are you woody a little white piano
you know what i mean
yeah it's tough to be an artist in the
bronx no well
i get upstage uh a guy runs over to me
stage man it says robert de niro
he's in your dressing room just saw the
show i want to talk to you
i said bob deniro in my dressing room
they said yeah
so [ __ ] so i go in the dressing room and
there's bob you know
sitting there he's like sure
what a show great show man he was best
one-man show ever saw
as i was like that he goes look chess
and i
and i said i know bob i know he goes
like i really want to do
i said bob this how crazy i was i said
bob you know i got to play sonny and i
got to write
he goes i know i know he goes let me
tell you what i feel he goes
if you sell us they're going to come to
me anyway so
listen to me he goes you should play
sonny you'll be great
and you should write the screenplay
because it'll be honest it'll be real
he goes i'll play your father and i'll
direct it
and if you shake my hands that's the way
it'll be i shook his hand
and that's what happened and then you
guys went out to meet some black girls
and we went on
because there's two italians that like
black girls it's you and bob de niro
yeah
it's actually actually bob and i went to
the cotton club together we had fun
hey there's stuff that you really are
afraid to say
are the things you should say because
that's where the goal is
sure and you know who told me that
arthur miller wow the great playwright
yeah i did uh
uh a workshop with him um
bridge uh view from the bridge
and he and i he knew i was a writer and
i spoke them
about writing and he told me that when
you're writing and the things that
you're afraid to edit
that's what you should leave in yeah
that's where the goal is that's what it
is leave all the zagats
yeah leave everything yeah
[Laughter]
no edits at all the richard gere part
keep it nice giannis is fall greek and
the honest wife is half sicilian giannis
is saying because his wife is half
sicilian that entitles him to a gomade
but he can always tell her i say hey
it's your culture it's yours
let me tell you something let me tell
you the italians
the italians in italy the priests yeah
the
priest tells the girl yeah what's the
day of the getting married
you know he's going to have a commander
you know he's going to have a good one
so just whatever you do don't let it
bother you it's going to be okay
yeah the freaking priests have gone yeah
yeah i try to tell my wife all the time
yeah i i think it's
yeah i'm getting a goomar for you it's
your culture i don't want it
michael you're sicilian yeah you're
doing it to respect your culture have a
good money
you gotta get a good yeah chaz i got to
ask you what was it like working with
woody allen
william was great great well he doesn't
talk to you
right you know if he talks to you that's
not a good sign
if you're shooting the movie and he
starts to talk to you a lot that means
you're going to get fired probably
really yeah because if you start telling
you no no don't do that do this
and i i went to him i said woody what
about he goes no no just
do what you want judge do whatever you
want interesting and so he let me improv
but let me do a lot of me and
he let a lot of us improv some people he
didn't let him pro right every movie i
ever did you have the script
i was signed by the cast hermetically
sealed
except for chris's pilot you [ __ ] do
that in the fire that's in the urinal
boulevard i love how italians always
have it
give a nickname and sometimes that
nickname or oftentimes that nickname is
the person's worst quality right yeah
oh always every time it's the worst part
yeah my favorite was my friend
jesse his father grew up in bensonhurst
and they said there was a kid that
didn't come out of his house before five
o'clock so they called them they called
them
sammy the mole they got him the moles
yeah
now the best thing i ever saw was i was
at chazz's restaurant
was sitting down eating chad's got on a
black you know chaz is look the black
turtleneck
[ __ ] black jacket sit down he gets
sauce on his turtleneck one of the
waiters comes over brings him another
turtleneck
they just had another turtleneck we had
another black turtleneck comes in with a
fresh turtleneck
if you were to rent cuisines is italian
number one and it's not even close
not even called time as a matter of fact
chess is it a little disrespectful if
somebody says
something other than italian cuisine
even though i know you support all
different races
but if they say what food italian it's a
little disrespectful
well why is you know pizza the biggest
selling thing in the world
not because the chinese made it yeah
absolutely and they but they did make
the virus
yeah but they did make spaghetti the
chinese if the chinese keep trying to
claim credit on spaghetti it's somebody
with marco polo and i want to say [ __ ]
you italians made spaghetti
[Music]
huh